On va accueillir d'ignes marnés devant eux.
Non, ce sont des hommes, des envahisseurs. Nous devons les combattre, les anéantir.
Ils ont des armes redoutables. Ils se sont rendus maîtres de la foudre.
Cela peut être très dangereux pour notre peuple.
Ils ne sont qu'une poignée, et notre armée est nombreuse, puissante.
S'il faut les combattre, nous les vaincrons sans peine.
Ne perdons pas de temps, attaquons-les !
Oui, ils demandent de l'or, toujours de l'or. C'est plutôt troublant.
Vous ne pensez pas à l'or et le métal des dieux ?
Non, c'est seulement parce qu'ils sont cupides.
Je comprends ta fougue, fruit de ta jeunesse,
cher neveu et gendre Kouotemok.
Mais nous, les anciens que seule la sagesse doit guider,
nous devons nous poser toutes ces questions.
Il y a eu des présages.
L'éclipse du soleil, les comètes dans le ciel,
les chutes d'Aérolith, et maintenant notre volcan,
le popo catépelte qui crache du feu.
Les prophètes nous ont annoncé que des êtres viendraient de là où naît le soleil.
C'est de là qu'ils viennent et ils nous offrent des pierres vertes,
message des dieux.
Ne sont-ils pas leur envoyés ? Qu'en pense notre grand-prêtre ?
Le seigneur Du Carrero m'a amené une de ses servantes pour qu'elle me conte son rêve.
Il me semble que vous devriez écouter son récit.
La déesse Cuero a péri, mère des dieux, m'est apparue en rêve et elle m'a dit
Vous devez abandonner la pratique des sacrifices humains.
Cessez de faire battre les tambours, sinon demain tout sera brisé.
Il n'y aura plus de temple ni de bûcher sacré.
Avant peu, tout redeviendra désert, car voici que d'autres hommes se présentent.
Le divin Quetzalcoatl, notre aimable et doux seigneur, avait la même coiffe, le même teint pâle, la même barbe que les nouveaux venus.
Et il avait dit qu'il reviendrait l'année des roseraies pour rétablir son autorité.
Et nous sommes justement l'année des roseraies.
Nos dieux haïssaient la violence. Ne les fâchons pas une fois de plus.
Temple, édifice en pierre construit sur l'eau, tout cela ressemble à un conte enchanté.
Il n'y a pas une ville comme celle-là dans tout l'Occident.
De telles choses n'avaient jamais été vues ou même rêvées.
D'ailleurs, ne rêvions-nous pas nous-mêmes ?
En avant !
Le roi vous souhaite la bienvenue à vous et à tous vos amis.
Prends ça.
La bien, le symbole de la conquête...
Du verre filet.
Un pur joyau.
Pour les bergers Cortés et ses hommes, Moctezuma va mettre tout un palais à leur disposition.
Mets deux hommes sur la terrasse.
Allez-y !
Tépice-toi, trailer !
Fais mettre un canon à cet endroit, Pedro.
Oui, Hernando.
Au revoir.
Mon poisson !
Jour, venez goûter à mes piments !
Une balle tunique ?
C'est très saillant, ça !
Alors, en dites-vous !
Quand nous arrivâmes, comme nous n'avions jamais vu une chose pareille,
nous fûmes stupéfaits d'une telle multitude de marchandises et de gens.
Et de l'ordre et de l'organisation qui régnaient dans tout.
Une fois, deux fois deux cents à gauche pour les belles esclaves !
Qu'est-ce que banane ?
Nien ?
Papa !
On fait goûter !
Attendez !
Diable, machin !
Très joli !
Non, deux d'un don, deux d'un don.
Vichy Lobo savait la face large et des yeux difformes, épouvantables.
Son corps était saint de serpents gigantesques.
Quant à Tescat et Pouka, qui étaient le dieu des enfers,
ils portaient autour du corps comme des petits diables dont les queues semblaient des serpents.
Je veux que tu dises à sa majesté que ces dieux me semblent bien méchants.
Nous adorons nos dieux et nous les tenons pour bon comme le sont certainement les vôtres, Seigneur.
Si vous nous laissiez dresser ici une croix et placer l'image de la Vierge, vous verriez la crainte de vos idoles.
Seigneur Malinche, si j'avais su deviner tes paroles déshonorantes, je ne t'aurais jamais montré nos dieux.
Maintenant, je vous prie de vous retirer.
De la Vierge ici ? Mais c'est assez bizarre, on dirait que ça sonne creux.
Oh, c'est la lumière.
C'est formidable, c'est le trésor des Aztèques.
Arrêtez, je vous interdis de prendre quoi que ce soit.
Ce serait du vol, il faut refermer ce mur.
On trouvera un autre moyen.
Attendez, il me vient tout à coup une bonne idée.
Voilà le plan que nous allons mettre à exécution.
Salut à toi, Majesté.
J'apprends que des hommes à toi ont attaqué ma garnison de Veracruz.
Et les coupables doivent se rendre à Mexico pour répondre de leurs actes.
En attendant, Seigneur, il convient que tu viennes dans notre palais.
Nous te servirons avec obéissance.
Je refuse. Peu m'importe d'avoir des juliers obéissants.
Vous n'avez pas à discuter, vous avez à obéir.
Et si vous élevez la voix, vous êtes un homme mort.
C'est bien, c'est sans doute la volonté des dieux
Coupables ont été punis, seigneur
Maintenant, il te faut faire serment d'allégeance à notre majesté catholique
Voici Staxi Natal, prêtresse chargée de l'entretien du sanctuaire de nos dieux
Ne me parlez pas de vos dieux, ce sont de mauvaises idoles
Quand dont accepterez-vous de louer notre dieu fait de miséricorde et de bonté ?
Laissez-nous du temps pour comprendre vos mystères et vos dieux
Les nôtres, nous les connaissons bien et ne vous en déplaise, ils nous semblent bons
Ce n'est pas vrai, il n'y a que le diable, Satan, pour accepter des sacrifices humains
Il faut que ça cesse.
Il faut oser pour Dieu.
Non, attendez, mais qu'est-ce que vous allez faire ?
Vous avez eu tort, Malinche, de vous attaquer à nos dieux.
Il nous ordonne maintenant de vous faire la guerre, de vous détruire tous.
Alors si j'ai un bon conseil à vous donner, Malinche, partez sans tarder.
Quittez cette ville où vous serez tous massacrés.
D'ailleurs, 18 de vos navires viennent d'aborder nos côtes.
Vous allez pouvoir repartir avec vos frères.
Oui.
1300 hommes de Velázquez viennent de débarquer pour nous ramener à Cuba.
C'est Narvaez qui les commande, je lui ai envoyé un émissaire pour lui expliquer la situation.
Qu'est-ce qu'il vous a répondu ?
Qu'ils se mettaient tout de suite en marche contre nous.
Qu'est-ce que tu décides capitaine ?
Nous les attaquerons à Saint-Pola avec l'aide de nos alliés Totonac.
Bernal, envoie des messagers à Sandoval pour qu'ils nous rejoignent avec tous ces hommes.
Toi Pedro, tu vas rester ici, tu tiendras la ville avec une garnison.
Mais du calme, je ne veux pas d'histoire.
Ah, tu peux compter sur moi capitaine.
J'ai mis sus à tous ces maudits païens !
Avez-vous fait ça ? Tous ces gens ne vous avaient rien fait, aucun mal !
Ils ne faisaient que chanter et danser paisiblement.
Ce sont tous des sauvages et des païens.
Parfaitement, des païens et des sauvages, alors bon débarras !
Oh Dieu !
Tant des nôtres tués !
Ils n'étaient même pas armés.
Les hommes blancs sont mauvais.
On ne va pas se laisser tous massacrer.
Le fautif, c'est Moctezuma.
Il s'est laissé berner par ces diables d'étrangers.
Nous devons les chasser de chez nous et les abattre l'un après l'autre.
C'est sauvage !
Oh !
Serville !
Laissera bien !
Sauvez ! Nous sommes sauvés, je vous dis !
Vous savez bien qu'on gagnerait, c'est un paix s'ils ne comprennent que la force.
Le chef est revenu, je le reconnais.
On a permis de partager avec eux l'or du Mexique.
Mais on n'en est pas là, qu'est-ce que tu as fait pour les enrager à ce point ?
Je m'étonnerais pas que tu leur aies joué un tour à ta façon.
Ce sont tous des païens et des sauvages !
Alonso, fais donner les canons !
Bernard et Pedro, suivez-moi, nous allons tenter une sortie, préparez-vous !
Feu !
Il n'arrivera pas comme ça.
Je crois qu'il serait plus sage de faire intervenir l'empereur Moctezuma.
Oui, tu as raison, Bernal.
Et ces combats, les hommes sont pour nous plus que nos frères.
Ce sont des dieux.
Ils ont massacré nos femmes et nos enfants.
Ce sont des sauvages, ce ne sont pas des dieux.
Des démons que nous devons détruire.
Écoutons plus ce que nous dit cette femme d'Espagnol.
C'est un homme-ville, il faut le punir.
Si on n'a plus que les ennemis, on ne tiendra pas devant cette foule déchaînée.
Il faut partir au plus vite, sinon nous serons tous massacrés.
S'en aller, c'est ridi. Encore faudrait-il pouvoir ? Ils ont coupé tous les ponts.
Bernal, je te charge de faire construire un pont portatif.
Tu prendras 150 soldats pour le manœuvrer.
Sandoval, avec 100 hommes, tu nous ouvriras la voie.
200 hommes et 200 indiens pour l'artillerie.
Alvarado, tu assureras l'arrière-garde avec une centaine d'hommes.
Alonso, toi, tu resteras avec moi, au centre,
avec 200 hommes pour porter secours à tous ceux qui en auront besoin.
Est-ce que c'est compris ?
Mais avant, une dernière chose à régler.
Monsieur Cristobal de Guzman, trésorier du roi,
Voici le cinquième du trésor qui revient à Sa Majesté. Veuillez le mettre à l'abri et vérifiez.
Occupez-vous-en. Emmenez-le.
En ce qui concerne le reste, servez-vous, messieurs.
Il vous plaira.
Comment donner une idée de cette nuit ?
La noche triste.
Que dire de la multitude de guerriers qui déferlaient sur nous ?
De ces canaux qui entraînaient nos compagnons vers les sacrifices ?
De cette épouvante qui nous entourait ?
Et qu'un cavalier s'élançait contre les Mexicains ?
Ceux-ci sautaient dans l'eau.
Tuaient le cheval à coups de longues lances, puis écrasaient le cavalier.
Dans ces conditions, dépourvus d'armes à feu, sans une arbalète, plongés dans la nuit noire, que pouvions-nous faire ?
Sinon foncez à coups d'épée vers le rival.
À peine parvenus sur la terre ferme, près de nos alliés indiens, Cortès fit volte-face pour porter secours aux retardataires.
Hélas, ils n'allèrent pas bien loin.
Alvarado, que sont devenus tes autres hommes ?
Hélas, capitaine, ils sont tous morts, nous sommes les seuls survivants, il est inutile que vous alliez plus loin.
À ces mots, les yeux du capitaine Cortez s'emplirent de larmes.
En six jours de combat, nous avions parcouru 40 kilomètres à peine.
Tous nos hommes, sans exception, étaient blessés.
Quant aux pertes...
Nous avons perdu 600 de nos hommes et les deux tiers de nos alliés de l'Axcaltec,
mais ma détermination reste intacte.
Nous retournerons à Mexico.
Les hommes continuaient de tomber et à notre passage, les Mexicases criaient
« Allez, chien, allez ! C'est la mort qui vous attend ! »
Chef, chef, on les a vus, ils sont des milliers, c'est incroyable !
Ils étaient environ 200 000 devant Totumba.
Il ne restait plus qu'à recommander notre âme à Dieu.
C'est alors que Cortés prit cette décision incroyable.
En avant, messieurs, fonçons sur eux pour Dieu et pour le roi !
Ça a eu la gentillesse de nous faire parvenir des renforts.
Les Tlaxcaltecs nous seront restés fidèles.
Il ne nous manque plus que des bateaux pour attaquer Mexico par la lagune.
Tu veux bien t'en charger, Bernal ?
Tu es un bon charpentier, Martin Lopez.
Je compte sur toi pour nous fabriquer des navires.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites ?
Vous voulez que je construise des navires en plein milieu des terres, comme ça ?
On les construira en pièces détachées et on les fera transporter à dos d'hommes.
Et avec quoi je vais vous les fabriquer, hein ?
Tu vois la forêt là ? Eh bien elle est faite d'arbres.
Avec les arbres, on fait des poutres, des planches, des navires.
C'est très joli tout ça, mais où je vais trouver les charpentiers qu'il me faut, moi ?
Il t'en faut combien, Lopez ? 100 ?
1 000 ? 10 000 ?
Ouais, c'est alors...
En avance à Mexico, tous à Mexico !
En 1221, Cortés est de retour devant Mexico.
Messieurs, notre objectif est d'assiéger la ville.
Nous partagerons nos troupes en quatre compagnies.
Les cavaliers attaqueront 3 par 3 ou 5 par 5 pour s'épauler.
Recommandez aux fantasins de serrer les rangs.
Alvarado, de ton côté, tu couperas l'aqueduc de Chapultepec qui alimente la cité en eau potable.
Nous attaquerons avec les brigandats par la lagune et nous empêcherons leur pirogue de ravitailler la ville.
Nous les affamerons !
Les hommes tombent comme...
Quelle est donc cette maladie, maître ?
Ah, cette maladie, c'était la variole apportée par les Blancs et la peste aussi.
Oh, tes moques, les Blancs ont offert une reddition honorable. Ne peux-tu l'accepter ?
Les hommes l'en mentent, il vaut mieux que nous mourions plutôt que d'être à la merci de ceux qui feront de nous des esclaves et qui nous tortureront pour savoir où est l'or.
Parole ô combien prophétique que nous rapporte Bernal Diaz.
J'espère qu'il continue à résister. On n'y arrivera pas comme ça.
On va changer de tactique. Au fur et à mesure de notre progression, nous allons tout détruire sur notre passage. Ragez la mine !
Je suis venu pour le bien de mon peuple. France Poignard et tue-moi.
Cortés ne le tua pas tout de suite. Il le mit d'abord au supplice pour qu'il révèle où était l'or.
Comme il s'obstinait à se taire, Cortès le fit étrangler.
La fin de Mexico-Tenochtitlan va marquer la fin de la civilisation aztèque.
À un monde magique, quoique cruel, va succéder ce que l'on nomme la civilisation occidentale.
Culte des richesses, exploitation des indigènes, esclavage, que voulez-vous ?
On manquait de bras.
La population indigène décimée par les guerres et les maladies était tombée de 20 à 1 million d'âmes.
Pour les Hidalgos, venus d'Espagne, dans ce vaste pays déjà conquis,
travaillaient de leurs mains, poc, quelle horreur !
À Madrid, entre-temps, après cette conquête, on complote contre Cortès.
Celui-ci va s'embarquer pour tenter de se justifier auprès de l'empereur Charles Quint.
Sept ans plus tard, il n'a toujours pas pu le rencontrer.
Et un jour, sur une route près de Valladolid...
Qui est cet homme ?
Je suis celui qui a donné à votre majesté plus de royaumes et de villes.
Quel nom a hérité de ses ancêtres ?